[Music]
take collider crew Haley here we are in
freakin Norway where Universal Home
Entertainment has sent us out here to
pick up some viking tips just in time
for the release of How to Train Your
Dragon the hidden world now precedent
colwiz books were famously inspired by
her family's island off the coast of
scotland but don't you worry because
norway has some big viking energy all of
its own and we're going to show you what
it's all about starting here at the stug
assigned viewpoint then we're going on
Scandinavia's biggest zipline and
terrified will be throwing axes I'm also
terrified I'm going to be chatting with
series creator Dean Dubois and star Jay
Baruchel and we're going to show you the
whole trip from top to tail - stay tuned
for all of it
[Music]
[Music]
that's cold on the face if they stray
fears feel a lot more like a dragon now
it's worth it do it
we're at the Viking village in good
Vagan where I have been earning little
beads for all of my accomplishments I
made bread
I made thread I am not good at that I
have done archery I'm actually pretty
good at that which is an amazing
surprise and now we're gonna go throw
some axes which makes me really nervous
I think I have what a taste for Viking
hood personally can I do another one
yeah
I think this just goes to show don't
doubt yourself you can be a Viking you
can be a dragon writer do whatever you
want throw axes look at that is amazing
thank you so much you're an amazing
teacher
you're welcome you made it and maybe we
keep you here now yes yeah all of us
Ahriman all right folks this is it this
is the end of an amazing trip I'm so
lucky to have been a part of this I want
to say thank you to Norway for having me
thank you to Universal for bringing me
over we get to visit our own hidden
world and the one and only toothless is
here with me I'm pretty much an official
Viking at this point you saw I'm a
killer with an axe and now I have a
dragon to weigh out thank you for
joining us on this amazing journey if
you feel as inspired as hi to be sure to
check out How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world when it arrives on blu-ray
May 21st thanks for coming